اجتماع للمطبخ الامني للحكومه الباكستانيه
بمشاركه القيادتين السياسيه والعسكريه
الاجتماع جدد التنديد باعمال الشغب
والتخريب التي طالت منشات ومرافق خاصه
وعامه من بينها مرافق تابعه للجيش متواعدا
مخطط ومنفذ الهجمات باجراءات صارمه
اجتماع لجنه الامن القومي يعبر عن تضامنه
مع الجيش الباكستاني ويدين هذه الحوادث
سياخذ القانون مجراه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه والاداريه اللازمه لمنع تكرار
ما جرى لن تتم معاقبه اي شخص دون مبرر
لكننا لن نتهاون مع المذنبين ممن خططوا
وحرضوا على التخريب هم بلا شك مذنبون
بالارهاب
عمران خان نفاي صله له ولحزبه باحداث
الشعب والتخريب التي تلت اعتقاله متهما في
المقابل عناصر في الامن بافتعالها لتبرير
ما وصفها بالحمله الامنيه ضد قاده ونشطاء
حزبه داعيا الى تشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله
ومجددا دعوه انصاره للتظاهر
لقد حان الوقت للتضحيه من اجل الحريه
الحقيقيه ومقاومه ما يقوم به بعض الاف من
عناصر الشرطه فعندما يرفض الشعب هذه
القسوه كما رفض النيل من الدستور والقضاء
ويطالب باختيار ممثلي عندها ستصبحون
احرارا اكسروا صنم الخوف وعندما ادعوكم
للنزول للشارع تظاهروا سلميه لنيل حقوقكم
وحرياتكم
وفيما يواجه عمران خان وقاده حزبه قائمه
طويله من القضايا والبلاغات اصدر مجلس
وبقرارا للتضامن مع الجيش وادانه مرتكبي
اعمال الشغب فيما نفهم مسؤولون حكوميون
وجود اي خطه لحظر حزب الانصاف من العمل
السياسي ويرى مراقبون ان رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان امام خيارات صعبه اما
الوضوح لضغوط الحكومه ومواجهه الاتهامات
ضده او استمرار التصعيد والمواجهه وتحمل
اي عواقب قد تطال قاده حزبه وربما تماسكه
عبد الرحمن المزيني العربيه اسلام اباد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات